Muchas Gracias, alcaldesa,
punto 81 del programa de izquierda unida podemos
para las elecciones municipales de 2 023
reducirá 1 máximo de 2.5 salarios mínimos
interprofesionales.
Los sueldos brutos de los concejales y concejales.
¿Qué implicaría esto
con el salario mínimo interprofesional de 2 024
que el gobierno de su Madre y el partido socialista
Han vuelto a subir recientemente?
Los €1 134 actuales de salario mínimo interpersonal.
Por este factor multiplicador de 2.5
nos darían €2 835 al mes,
que por 14 pagas son €39 690 brutos al año
y no los actuales €50 249.88,
que supone 1 dedicación exclusiva.
Sin entrar a considerar que la alcaldesa,
los delegados de área y delegados de servicio
cobren algo más.
Somos caros, muy caros.
Muy bien. Tenemos que hacer las cosas para compensar
este gasto a la Ciudad.
Y fíjense que me incluyo
aunque no forme parte del equipo de gobierno.
Lo digo porque parece que
cuando saco el tema del dinero
hay susceptibilidades heridas
y como que no se puede mencionar,
me da la impresión,
como persona nueva en este Mundo de la política,
que todos creen que hacen su trabajo mejor que nadie.
Y lamento decirles que esa visión es bastante errónea.
En fin, volviendo a lo que comentaba
al principio de mi intervención,
si en algún momento
tienen en cuenta la propuesta de este grupo
para bajarnos esos sueldos,
cuenten con el apoyo de concejal de izquierda unida.
Por supuesto. Votaremos no. Gracias